in leipzig vielleicht deswegen die gute
laune läuft seit heute der spannendste
cdu-parteitag ich lege mich fest
mindestens der woche meine damen und
herren was wird aus der letzten
deutschen volkspartei und hat annegret
kramp-karrenbauer als chefin da
überhaupt noch eine zukunft
das sind die großen fragen die sich ganz
deutschland stellte meine klar in
leipzig da lege ich mich auch fest
findet garantiert keine revolution statt
so was gehört nicht zur dna der cdu
trotzdem natürlich ein spannender
parteitag war ja keiner mehr weiß wofür
dieser verein überhaupt noch steht
symptomatisch dieses bild vom konrad
adenauer haus in berlin da klaut gestern
ein typ von greenpeace cee und latsch
seelenruhig damit
ja die ist dann wie in der sesamstraße
durch berlin gelaufen und hat passanten
verkaufen wollte aber keiner
ja die union von heute lechzt nach
führung nach orientierung
ist ja auch klar als ausgleich für das
große vakuum namens merkel
was genau müsste die partei also machen
um sich eines tages doch mal wieder von
der spd zu unterscheiden
ich sage da sind konkrete ideen gefragt
wir reden heute über die zukunft die
zukunft ist noch nicht ausgemacht sie
liegt in unserer hand die zukunft ist
offen und wir müssen die chancen nutzen
die im morgen liegen und ab das so kommt
oder nicht das liegt ein gutes stück an
uns es kann passieren aber es muss nicht
passieren
konfuzius sagt zukunft kann passieren
muss aber nicht einmal anderthalb
stunden hat die so geredet
ich übertreibe nicht 90 minuten flog
dieses rhetorik feuerwerk den
cdu-delegierten um die ohren
zum glück müssen wir sagen hatte er
irgendeine schlaue firma zollstöcke als
werbegeschenk in der halle verteilt und
wie dieser mann hier beweist
[Applaus]
ja zollstöcke die droge des kleinen
mannes bis jetzt zumindest bis heute
abend hat in leipzig keiner der
möchtegern revoluzzer von märz bis kuban
offen anna k k stuhl gesägt das machen
die kleinen feiglinge und nur vor
parteitagen aus dem hinterhalt
dabei hat er gerät in den ball muss man
sagen wirklich schon auf den
elfmeterpunkt gelegt wenn ihr der
meinung seid dass dieser weg den ich
gemeinsam mit euch gehen möchte nicht
der weg ist denn ihr für den richtigen
halt er lasst es uns heute aussprechen
und lasst es uns heute auch beenden
ich möchte das aussprechen gegenwärtig
in der zelle emotionaler moment
ansonsten diskutiert die cdu in leipzig
vor allem über ein großes thema
digitalisierung das ist im moment
ohnehin deutschlands top thema alle
reden über digitalisierung anfang der
woche trafen sich ja schon unsere grob
auf schloss meseberg in brandenburg zu
großen digital klausur
ja und
da gab es einiges zu besprechen da in
diesem hanni und nanni laden wo die sich
da eingekerkert haben überlegen sie mal
selbst die netzabdeckung mit 4g wir
reden nicht von 5 g selbst die mit 4g es
bei uns schlechter als in albanien ist
kein witz hier original live schalte zum
funkloch gipfel in der ard er soll es
auch mehr begleitforschung geben die
jetzt mehr gefördert werden soll und
zudem um eben neue im grundstück und ich
fürchte wenn man funkloch meseberg
leider ist die verbindung damit
abgebrochen
ja so bloch oder wie die einheimischen
dort sagen brandenburg ja jetzt will die
groko selber mit ihrem also letztlich
mit meinem geld 5000 neue funkmasten
aufstellen in ganz deutschland von anni
scheuer in meseberg verkündet gute idee
oder doch nur funk masturbation ich sage
ich sage beides ist es beides denn damit
bügeln sie ihre eigenen fehler der
letzten jahre aus zum beispiel dass man
telekom und co bei der ausschreibung nie
verpflichtet hat eine mindestfläche
abzudecken
auf dem land verdienen diese konzerne zu
wenig und deswegen ist das hier auf dem
land die realität david ortmann versucht
zu telefonieren das geht hier digital
allerdings nur wenn alle anderen im
rathaus nicht im netz sind
es geht schon wieder nicht du musst
unbedingt aus dem netz haus höher auf
pornos zu gucken
der bürgermeister muss
[Applaus]
es fließt
noch ein schöner vergleich in portugal
haben knapp 90 prozent der haushalte
inzwischen einen glasfaseranschluss bei
uns sind es 8,5 prozent die
bundesnetzagentur nicht irgendwer die
bundesnetzagentur hat gerade erklärt 56
kilobyte sein doch auch okay ältere
zuschauer werden sich erinnern das war
die geschwindigkeit vor isdn ja was wir
machen das grenzt wirklich an digitale
empfängnisverhütung wirklich und jetzt
kommt garantiert die wände freunde mit
unserem tollen neuen digital kabinett
denn da sitzen wirklich nur die besten
der besten
das digital kabinett da haben wir alle
minister gefragt ob sie glauben dass sie
da rein gehören und alle haben ja gesagt
erinnert so ein bisschen an das
schulsystem von bremen
so kinder wer glaubt alles das aufs
gymnasium gehört ja so wenigstens
arbeitet familienministerin geht jetzt
an der digitalen behörde
zeit wird's in berlin steht man gern
einmal die ganze nacht an für eine warte
marke vom standesamt ist tatsache
und nur mal zum vergleich in estland
gibt es nur noch drei vorgänger für die
man zwingend persönlich aus amt muss
scheidung hauskauf hochzeit drei sachen
die einen sicher ruinieren aber ist eine
andere geschichte ja erst land so weit
sind wir in deutschland noch lange nicht
aber selbst das kann man ja positiv
sehen jetzt endlich wohl mesco
weltkulturerbe die deutsche behörde im
tosenden sturm der digitalisierung
bleibt sie eine insel der ruhe wir
garantieren unsere mitarbeiter eine
einmalige mischung aus professionellen
desinteresse und offener feindseligkeit
mit technik von gestern für morgen und
übermorgen
genießen sie den beruhigend modrigen
geruch von stempelkissen und
abgestandenem filterkaffee
wir sind und bleiben für sie offline
denn wir wollen dass das internet eine
verheißung bleibt genau
porsche gehört entschleunigung für die
ewigkeit
die viscom weltkulturerbe die analoge
deutsche behörden
digitalisierung aber seien wir unserer
gruppe auch mal ein bisschen dankbar
neue funkmasten kommen funkmasten sind
quasi das must have der saison
gleichzeitig gibt es aber auch wissen
sie jede menge bürgerinitiativen die
gegen solche teile vor ihrer haustür
klagen ist ja auch ein totaler trend
überall wird geklagt genau deswegen
kommen wir auch unsere stromtrassen gar
nicht so ran wobei ich in sachen
stromtrassen mancher anwohner auch
verstehen kann wenn man nicht genau auf
die schaukel zum beispiel setzt wie
kriegen eine geflutscht teilweise oder
die gesichter vibrieren von den kindern
mama ich kann auch nicht zur schule mein
gesicht vibriert natürlich lustig
trotzdem überall wird nur noch geklagt
auch gegen windräder vor allem gegen
windräder laut peter altmaier es
neuestem gesetzentwurf müssen windräder
in deutschland mindestens 1000 meter von
der nächsten siedlung entfernt sein und
fünf häuser gelten dann allerdings
tatsächlich schon ansiedlung das war
wirklich der todesstoß für diese
energieform für die windenergie
sebastian pufpaff leitet die
arbeitsgemeinschaft arroganter latte
macchiato trinken der großstädter die
langsam die schnauze voll haben von der
renitenten landbevölkerung griffiger
name abrufbar
ich hab so verstanden ihnen reicht
langsam aber hallo herr mir brennt die
nudel schon vom hörensagen
wenn wir unser symbol ist ja nicht
umsonst durchgestrichene misthaufen und
das geht ja jetzt nicht generell gegen
die netten menschen vom land unserer
regeln zum beispiel der ist ja in
harsewinkel bei gütersloh aufgewachsen
und da weiß ich der onkel buchbar muss
lauter und langsames regel zeit weil der
kleine rolle die ganzen ammoniak dämpfe
von der gülle leingarten
das können sie gar nicht sehen aber da
hatte ich auch gemischten gefühlen es
keine arroganz das sind fakten ja aber
man kann so was die windenergie halbhoch
darf doch nicht jeden die bevölkerung
durchsetzen ja das heißt bevölkerung ich
sage immer was im wald lebt es ist ja
mehr tier als mensch und da braucht man
als stadt halt auch eier in der hose und
eine schrumpelige rosine
wenn ich den altmaier schon höre ja
dafür die akzeptanz in der bevölkerung
entweder ist klimawandel eine
existenzfrage oder nicht stattdessen
alle drei meter nennen 37 initiativen
arbeiten jetzt zusammen
[Musik]
eingeladen
kurz faktisch in der windenergiebranche
sind seit 2016 über 40.000 stellen
weggefallen how gibt hier keine sau
jeder will sauberen strom aber bitte
keine windräder schnelles internet aber
ohne funkmasten wenn das so weitergeht
könnten wir in zehn jahren alle wieder
vom baum
na ja gut er puffer man könnte die
anwohner ja auch endlich mal mehr an den
gewinnen der windkraft beteiligen wenn
es denn wenigstens ums geld gehe
aber die haben ja einfach nur ängste
stört persönlich an den anlagen dass sie
für mich eine optische bedrohung
darstellen vor allem auch nachts wenn
diese rot blinken dann blinken rote
lampe oder wie man in der eifel sagt des
auges toll aber diese praktischen
landeier wollen alle annehmlichkeiten
der modernen zeit aber wehe irgendwas
blind roth eher gut als arroganter
städter sagt sich das alles natürlich
leichter genau war in der stadt alles so
geil ist da darf ich von morgens bis
abends abgasen weg schnüffeln überall
lärm stelle sich mal vor wir haben sogar
ampeln die blinden manchmal selber das
sind schon zwei farben
ich wende mich jetzt mal direkt an
unsere zuschauer vom land ach du scheiße
liebe dorfbewohner liebe provinz disney
sehr geehrte hinterwäldler seit jahren
mit ihr nur um weil ihr die gleichen
geilen sachen haben wollt wie wir in der
stadt ich behaupte gott will gar nicht
dass jeder hund im sauerland
ruckelfreien netflix schauen kann ok
vorschlag kommt doch einfach mal aus dem
fenster
ihr seid dorf freiwillig in eure kämpfer
gezogen oder freiwillig nicht weggezogen
und wozu braucht ihr bitte finde ihr
habt doch hindern
[Musik]
dann kommt mehr keines und masten will
der kriegt ja auch kein internet wasser
und wenn ihr euch beschweren wollt dann
schreibt uns doch nie mehr hh heede
schöne grüße aus der stadt oder
sebastian buchbar sebastian durch die
straßen mit dem fuß
[Applaus]
ich fürchte nach diesem beitrag werden
uns in der tat alle e mails vom land
erreichen und wenn ich e mail sage meine
ich postkarten aber aber nochmals zurück
zum cdu-parteitag friedrich merz
friedrich merz der große revolutionär
sagt plötzlich er unterstützt annegret
kramp karrenbauer ja total loyal auf
einmal
der showdown fällt aus bitterer
rückschlag für alle die ihn als
cdu-vorsitzenden wollen also vor allem
für friedrich merz oder reicht es doch
noch für die kanzlerschaft fragt dietmar
wischmeyer
die 1000 wichtigsten politiker
deutschlands heute folge 991 friedrich
merz
aufgetaut aus dem permafrost des
sauerlandes erscheint 2018 eine
lichtgestalt am horizont der cdu es ist
er mehrfach hochbegabte friedrich merz
hier ein frühes bild von klein fritzchen
als problem
nature am ufer der möhnetalsperre
zurückgekehrt in die politik ist er nur
um rache zu nehmen an der grotten
kanzlerin merkel
und um zu beweisen dass alle seine ideen
auf einen bierdeckel passen
kurz und knackig formuliert wir brauchen
endlich via sozialste politik die in
deutschland jemals gemacht hat
das denken viele in der cdu aber sie
sagen es nicht also verkackt märz auf
seinen tausendsten putschversuchen und
ak das fettnäpfchen suchgerät aus
püttlingen bleibt vorsitzende
weil sie sich auskennt auch in der
digitalen welt
derselbe raum ist zunächst einmal keine
flüssige dimension missverständnis der
cyberraum ist das zimmer im altersheim
wo die spucke opis weggesperrt werden
friedrich merz weiss natürlich aus
diesem aufgescheuchten saarlands werken
wird niemals eine kanzlerin hätte nicht
mal ein eigenes flugzeug und pünktlich
den nächsten g 8 gipfel zu erreichen
dass friedrich der große schon er
kanzler material findet zumindest die
junge union
presse und sorgt auch gern ich eine
freundin dann ist der druck weg
nächster kanzler wird gar nichts
ja jakob von blackrock sondern armin
laschet der süße hobbit aus aachen im
auenland weil der die wirklich
relevanten fragen stellt sollte mal
wäsche noch mit dem wäschetrockner
trocknen oder sollte man sie nach
draußen hängen endlich war es mal einer
in diesen kleinen wonneproppen von der
zwieback packung nicht unser fritz lina
abgestorbene fichte aus dem sauerland
und nächste woche zeige ich ihnen via
kaka im cyberraum einen roboter trifft
und nicht mal der wir noch die hand
geben traurig
mein arzt hat mir verboten mich
weiterhin so aufzuregen
deswegen wollte ich euch allen einfach
nur einen schönen tag wünschen überall
lassen die ihre dreggsagg michl liegen
und hier last jetzt slx ein beschissenes
abo da
[Musik]